you guys are it seems like you're
inseparable you've done so much work
together you've known each other how
long
oh like 13 years or so probably i mean
at this point we've known of each other
for probably 20 years but
but but we're friends you know 13 14 did
you meet on supernatural
well that's a see there's a story there
because
i have seen rob benedict's work on on
television and in film and thought he
was a really talented guy and he's one
of those dudes that i would see at
auditions right because we're kind of
the same category
yeah of guy both hunters yeah both hunts
and it would be us it'd be dean kane you
know the youth
they're huge
[Laughter]
and so like we're like uh i'd cross
bobo's path a lot and
i'm one of those dudes like and rob
knows this about me like if i if i liked
you in something
i did there's no ego i will walk up and
be like god just watch an episode of tv
you run you just knock this
i'm like that i do that too all the time
yeah and some actor like i was
i like that guy but i don't want to show
my hand yeah i don't want to say that i
liked it because then you know
next time we're in the audition room
he'll think like he's got me and i think
he's got me so like i feel like i'm soft
so i i saw bubba a couple times i was
like oh man i'm a big fan
and the joke is and it's obviously been
blown up over time for a comedic effect
but in truth
rob would forget that we had met so i
would go to him like
rob benedict rich faye saw you and blah
blah blah
man that was just great oh thanks thanks
man thanks
yeah no seriously like really good yeah
yeah thanks thanks buddy thanks
and you know on our merry way we go then
i go to a pilot taping a buddy of mine
wrote
and there's rob it's one of the regulars
and i come down afterwards i'm like
robinx oh my god rich fate
look at you like yeah yeah thanks man um
then after two it became
like i ran into him on halloween well we
were doing supernatural we were
overlapping we weren't we were not
working in the same episodes but i would
see rob
like he was on the call sheet for the
next episode so we'd overlap and we'd
overlap in the apartment i remember like
oh rob benedict's moving in here after i
leave
so i'd leave like a funny outgoing
message like this is rob benedict's
apartment
you've reached me i'm with the shower it
could be hours
[Laughter]
landlines in the apartments somebody
shut their dog up
not anywhere this luna's luna barks luna
barks at friendlies
cuddles up to the enemy i am friendly i
almost yelled at my dog
shut up but they're not doing anything
it's fine um but so i run into robin
trick-or-treating he's out with his kids
two kids like they're cut out of
magazines i'm chasing my kids around
hurting them with a rake
and robbie he's there and i'm like rob
hey rich spade and he goes and he goes
hey hey man
with that look of i don't know who you
are you know that clear like glazed over
i'm like rich
spate supernatural you know medical
times
supernatural and he's like ah yeah no
hey hey
uh good to see you buddy good i gotta
you know go with
these better looking kids but i'll be
you know thanks for stopping
with these better looking kids all
lettuce that led up to this time
i was like grove no yeah
jesus how could you forget his face
none of this is true no this is actually
true this is true
you can't dispute this i go up i'm out
with my special lady friend my wife the
machete
and we go up to the bar at the arclight
to have a cocktail before
these screening and if you know that
area it's a small s
you know slender bar area and a couple
cocktail tables
and we sat down at one end and at the
far end i see
a young rob benedict and his wife molly
out for a date night themselves
and i'm like oh there's there's that guy
rob benedict and his wife
on a date night me and i go to the bar
and i order a drink
and he goes hey are you that guy from
supernatural i'm like yeah yeah
that guy and he looked over he goes
isn't that guy also from supernatural
yeah yeah that's rob benedict he's also
in supernatural and the guy's like oh
why aren't you guys talking to each
other let's just start from up here
i like he never remembers me man i just
i'm done
please please say he came up to you
please i didn't see him he didn't
was that man i didn't see him i just i
couldn't find any bartender
i didn't see him i remember see
my side of that whole story is that i
remember rich spate rich bait was really
uh he booked like 80 000 commercials
back in the day and so
when i used to do a lot of commercial
auditions he was always
in the waiting room and i remember like
if he was there
you're like he he had the job but
so i just kind of knew who he was and he
was also just really nice and he was a
nice guy so you you know you couldn't
hate on him
um so i just kind of knew his face i
remember meeting him at that pilot
taping
and i remember him at halloween i had
actually two young children
beautiful as they may be they're as you
well know rich a lot of work
so it was a little more like oh hey man
yeah hey man i got to run with the kids
hey
nice seeing you all right it wasn't
enough for old richie
wasn't enough i remember you looked at
my kids you go those are your kids
oh that's not sorry who are you who are
you richard spate
hey